hi guys my name is a challenge at bala
and i'm presenting the open devices
program how many of you have heard
before about the open devices program
from sony ok nice how many of you are
wrong developers or have built a wrong
before nice thank you so Who am I I'm a
software and hardware engineer that have
started the development with community
in 2006 with on XDA I have played with
HTC windows and Android devices and then
I have switched to Sony windows and
Android devices I have created the free
Xperia project in 2010 with the ambition
of unlocking the Xperia phones and
provide an open-source alternative in
2014 I have joined the Sony as the
manager of the open devices program open
devices program our goal is to provide
an innovation and development platform
we offer support for 21 devices and more
will come all based on welcome platform
starting from 2014 this project uses one
kernel for all devices one camera for
framework for all devices which it's
still working program progress and needs
0 patches to compile and work we provide
basic connectivity like gsm Bluetooth
NFC while wireless everything that you
get when you compile the Android from
sorry from google those are the
supported devices we support everything
from the old world core em to my msn
8226 like em to eat
t3 and t2 ultra up to the newest devices
that we have just launched and that is
the MSM 899 for including the z3 plus 85
compact g5g five premium and tablet
since all those devices are supported in
the same repository and the same kernel
the features that work on one will work
on all and if you apply a patch to fix
something on one of them you will
actually fix all devices the same thing
if you add the feature it will be on all
devices what are the steps to build and
flash this software you have to go to
our website and unlock your bootloader
you have to download and build the ASP
code you can after that start
experimenting with open source
possibilities and start innovation and
in the end you can think about future
IOT and why not repurposing as I was
saying before it's enough to go to our
website the address eating in the down
part of my slide and you will simply get
the ability to run unsigned Colonel
images after you unlock your bootloader
you can use your our hardware to flash
custom roms and create an experience and
the innovate to innovate on our hardware
please note that unlocking bootloader
will deactivate proprietary Sony
functions our goal with this program is
to provide as an as good as possible
vanilla OSP experience for unlocked
devices we want to provide a base for
custom roms writer we prioritize the
latest modems models we provide long
term
support for all devices including the
old ones like like I said the 2014
dual-core devices and you also get the
latest version of Android we have
published the guide how to build Android
M seven days after google has released
the open source code our ambition is to
drive innovation to work with external
community and developers sorry this is
the journal layout we have based it on
several branches so that you can easily
follow the changes and you so that you
can easily rebase on maybe a new kernel
version so you have a qualcomm base you
have misc welcome branch which is
patches from qualcomm that fix various
platform support misc up its patches
that come from different kernel project
and misc dev it's patches from us or
other community developers then you have
drivers which is the drivers used by our
hardware and you have platform
configuration which is mostly details
configuration in the same time you have
the hardware abstraction layer and we
are trying to provide compatibility with
existing Google one where is not
possible we are open sourcing the whole
and our goal is to use as few binaries
as possible because having binaries can
limit your innovation so even if you get
a hole with less functionality you can
still innovate since you have the code
but if you get only binaries let's say
you cannot do anything and then as I
have
promised a long time ago we have looked
into one of the most desired parts of
the open source and that is the open
source camera solution we are still
working on it but as you can see in in
my slide it supports all the platforms
in one code it also rewrite everything
clean so that you can reuse it and
innovate on it and we will release the
camera binaries which implement our
sensors I don't have a specific time
frame for it but soon it's all I can say
in this moment you will have a complete
hardware platform with a complete
software stack so that you can start
innovating on it since we want it to be
as transparent as possible this is the
current status and probably this is how
it will look on the initial launch
please note that the camera is developer
grade it is not matching the sony store
camera quality and also it has issues
with stability the whole reason for
releasing this camera early is so that
community can start innovating and so
that you can adjust your custom rom
trees to our new solution I know that in
the past a lot of you have hacked the
camera with worse results or let's say
fisheye bug and a lot of other problems
with this camera solution you have the
code or most of it and that means that
you can start innovating and there is no
longer the need to to hack and lose a
lot of weeks just trying to figure out
how it works and then you have the
android the android part it's the one
that all you always want to have the lay
does and with this program since
everything it's open source you can
always have the latest as I was
mentioning we have launched seven days
after Google em release we have launched
the guide so that you can build the same
happened with the lollipop Mr 17 days
after the release you had the guide you
had the new binaries so that you can
start innovating our goal is to drive
innovation and here I have some ideas of
what you can actually do with the open
devices program you can build custom
roms or and we have a good example and
good support from cyanogen aokp and
paranoid android but in the same time
maybe you don't want to build just
another custom room maybe you want to
experiment with different operating
systems and then you can start looking
on selfish you can start looking on a
bunt 0 and you can start looking on
Mozilla Firefox OS now there is not an
build Rome it is the possibilities for
you to innovate so you can you can
basically build any operating system
since everything it's open source and in
my next slide I have something that it's
already built Mozilla has published a
nice article about how to build Firefox
OS on our devices and the instructions
are in the down of my page down part you
can go and build your own Firefox OS 421
Sony devices for some of them you have
to add small differences because they
don't support all devices but you have
everything on github and also you can
see somebody actually two developers
have ported Firefox OS on our devices
based on the same program open devices
and it works nice it is still as buggy
as hell
but it shows the potential of
investigating or innovating on this
hardware and now because I have talked a
lot about innovation let's talk a little
about repurposing usually when your
phone it's old and you no longer use it
it just ends up in a drawer or if you
smash the screen then you always count
how much it will cost for you to repair
it and if the cost for a new screen is
too high you will simply throw it in a
drawer what happens if we think outside
the box and we think that we have a very
powerful from two to eight core platform
that has embedded connectivity it has
wireless and bluetooth it has gsm and
you have all the sensors cameras maybe a
battery or maybe you want to replace the
battery for repurposing and a display or
maybe the display it's also broken but
you have hdmi compare this one to a
regular development board which is
usually week and you can think of a lot
of project while i was in in Moscow for
droidcon Moscow a developer asked me if
he can build a web server on a board
like this with eight core system and
three gigabytes of RAM I think that you
can build a really nice web server you
can do a lot more than that your mind
sense sets the innovation bonds for this
one you just have a powerful hardware
and everything it's open source what you
can do with it it's simply up to you
this project was started in 2014 by Sony
for community and we try to
work as much as possible with community
so we have published source code
repository on github we are active on
XDA forum so that you can post questions
and get replies we have our own forum on
the sony website but that one it's only
for developers and then we have created
the reward Developer Program reward
developer program our rewards developers
that works with us so if a developer
contribute contributes comments back to
Sony those comments are counted every
two months and the person that has the
most accepted comments every two months
gets a new Sony device those are the
people that till now since the the
program has started have one one of our
devices and the respect from community
because they have fixed and helped
community get a better software as many
of you have already been part of the XDA
or Android BBQ my slides usually are
short and then I'm happy to hear more
about what do you think what do you like
and what would you like from this
program and what would you actually want
from us to help you so if you have any
ideas please speak the part with spare
parts I would say that it's easy to find
them on online sales from broken devices
we are selling phones
okay so no no ideas okay guys thank you
and see on online them